[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
نائب المتحدث باسم طالبان يصف داعش
بالظاهره التكفيريه ويقلل من تاثيرها في
افغانستان
في الرياض عشرات الاتفاقيات والاستثمارات
الملياريه
عمليه فصل السياميه العراقي تتواصل في
الرياض اخر المراحل تقترب من نهايتها
في رابعه ايضا
وادي الرمان حديث الناس في السعوديه
وتساؤلات حول تاريخه وواقعه اليوم
واستمرار جريانه
واعتماد الجيش والمجشوش طبقا وحلوى وطنيه
في السعوديه
نائب المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان بلال كريمي
قرار الاماره في افغانستان منع تعليم
المراه في الجامعه بانه من واجبها تنظيم
شؤون التعليم والتنميه في البلاد وفقا
لاحكام الشريعه وفي مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه قال ان نظام الطالبان منح المراه
حقوقا لم تكن موجوده في السابق
خير يوقفنا
ذكرنا ان الامارات الاسلاميه تتكون من
علماء وطلاب يهتمون بالعلوم والتربيه
والتعليم اكثر من اي فئه اخرى والاماره لا
تعارض تعليم اي شخص باي شكل من الاشكال
ولكنها مسؤوله عن تنظيم المراحل التربويه
والتعليميه وكل ما يتعلق بذلك فهي مسؤوله
وترى ان من واجبها ان يكون ذلك وفقا
لاحكام الشريعه الاسلاميه
والمبادئ الاسلاميه
فيها افغانستان ووصفه بالظاهره التكفيريه
غير المرئيه واكد ان الاماره قضت على 98%
من اوكار التنظيم مشيرا الى عدم وجود
حاضنه شعبيه له في افغانستان
ان ظاهره داعش تكفيريه ليس لها وجود مادي
ومرئي وملموس في بلادنا فبعد مجيء الاماره
الاسلاميه تم القضاء على
98% من عناصر التنظيم وتم تدميره او تاره
ولكن من المؤسف ان بعض الدوائر تدعمه من
خلال الاعلام او تموله الاستغلاله ولكن في
الممارسه العمليه ما نراه في الواقع
الميداني لبلدنا هذه الظاهره لا تشكل
تحديا كبيرا وليست مصدره قلق جاد للامن
الداخلي في بلادنا ولا يمكنه ان يشكل
تهديدا من افغانستان الى دول اخرى
همم ما قدر عشره وقدرتشيذي قرار النبي
داعش امرا مهما لكي نحتاج الى دول اخرى
لمواجهته داعش ليس تنظيما قويا وليسا مهما
ليتمكن من تجنيد الاشخاص عندنا وليس له
مناطق ثابته فحيث نجد نشاطا تخريبيا
منفردا تطارده قوات الدوله ومخابره
الاماره الاسلاميه ويتم تدميره
الافغاني اهلا وسهلا بك يا سيد احمد
ما قاله المتحدث باسم حركه طالبان في هذه
المقابله يتنافى كما يرى الكثير من
المراقبين الان لحركه تنظيم داعشان في
افغانستان تقرير تتحدث عن زياده اعداد
المجندين بل ان اكثر من يتم تجنيدهم وهم
من داخل حركه طالبه نفسها بالاضافه الى
تمدد وتوسع هجمات ايضا
لداعش خلال فتره الماضيه خاصه في الربع
الاخير ربما من 20022 في تحول نوعي حتى
لهذه العمليه
ما هي حقيقه تنظيم داعش في افغانستان
والعلاقه مع الطالبا
2015 كانت هي في البدايه تجمع الساقطين
منه طالبان افغانستان وطالبان باكستان
كانت تركز عملياتها في تلك الفتره قبل
سيطره الطالبان على على طالبان وحتى على
الحكومه الافغانيه السابقه
وكذلك تستهدف بعض التجمعات المدنيه وخصوص
من الاقليه الشيعيه في افغانستان ولكن بعد
السيد الطالبان في منتصف اغسطس 2021 ااه
تغير استراتيجيه تنظيم داعشان في
افغانستان
فاصبحت في البدايه كانت تستهدف بعض
المساجد والحسينيات ولكن من بعد ذلك اصبح
حتى تستهدف حتى البيتات الاجنبيه وكذلك
الجهات الحكوميه الوزارات تستهدف القيادات
داخل الطالبان ما عجزت قوه
داعش فرصه ثانيه
من طالبان حتى بعد سيطرتها على الحكومه في
على الحكم في افغانستان بين هؤلاء كانوا
قضوا اعمارهم جميعا في قتال الامريكان
قتال القوات الحكومه السابقه فهي اصبحت
يعني طريقه هي الوتر الحساسه التي تلعب
عليه داعش في جذب هؤلاء الاشخاص من خلال
اقناع بانهم حاربوا لمده 20 عام الغرب
والكفار والان اصبحت حكومتهم التي طالبان
تريد التقارب من الغرب لذلك هي هنا تستطيع
ان تحتضن هؤلاء وتجذبهم وتستطيع من ذلك
بانهم موظفين في الحكومه الان في الطالبان
وقوات الامن تستطيع ان ترسلهم لتنفيذ مهام
في مناطق حساسه داخل الكعبه ولو كان
مختلفه
على سبيل المثال في الربع الاخير من 2022
تم استهداف فندق يقيم فيه صينيون في
العاصمه كابل محاوله اغتيال السفير
الباكستاني محاوله استهداف السفاره
الروسيه في كابول تفجير مطار كابل في
بدايه هذه السنه التفجير امام مقر
الخارجيه الافغانيه مؤخرا
يعني تعامل طالبان هل همم او الى اي مدى
ادى الى تنام هذا الخطر هناك من يتحدث عن
انعدام للكفاءه استخفاف او تهاون وهناك من
يصل الى الى تقاطع في المصالح بين بين
تنظيم داعش
وبعض الحركه او الشخصيات داخل حركه
الطالبه عن الحاكمه ما مدى صحت ذلك
الذين استطاعوا الوصول الى هذه
التنفيذ هذه العمليات المؤخره همم مثلا
محاوله اغتيال السفير الباكستاني في كابل
نشر همم داعش نشرت الصوره همم
[موسيقى]
كانوا في مبنى مقابل للسفاره ونشر صوره
السفير وهو داخل السفاره يعني انه استطاع
الوصول ويعرفه ماذا يفعل السفير خلال
اوقات فراغه وكذلك وصولهم الى الفندق
الصيني في كابل يقيم في سنين من غير من
غير المعقول ان يقيم فيها افغاني شخصيه
اخرى اجنبيه ان لم تكن معروفه لذلك حدث
عمليات وحدث كذلك تفجير مطار كابول همم
الذي يجب الذكره انه يوم امس خلال التفجير
امام وزاره الخارجيه هناك ثلاثه نقاط
تفتيش فقط على الطريقه المؤدي الى بوابه
وزاره الخارجيه الشخص الذي استطاع يتجاوز
هذه النقاط التفتيش حتى يصل الى بوابه
وزاره الخارجيه ويقوم بالتفجير نفسه اعتقد
لا اعتقد انه شخص عادي او استطاع اختراقه
ما اعتقد انه لديه وسيله وطريقه استطاع ان
يتجاوز ثلاث نقاط تفتيش لان نقاط التفتيش
ليست مقتصره فقط على السيارات وانما حتى
على المشاه وحتى ان ذلك الشارع لا يمر به
اشخاص عاديين المواطنين العاديين لا يمرون
به حكم قرب من عده وزارات وحتى القصه
الرئاسي
فلذلك بعض الشخصيات في طالبان وبعض
المنتسبين الى طالبان همم
استطاع الداعش تجنيدهم داخليا
احدهم كان يعمل في مجلس الوزراء في طالبان
في رئاسه مجلس الوزراء في طالبان وهو الذي
خطط لتنفيذ عمليه مقتل رحمه الله حقاني
احد اكبر علماء طالبان في اغسطس 2022
وتم القبض عليه في نوفمبر ديسمبر فهذه
الشخصيات الذين يستطيعون الوصول الى
المنطقه الدبلوماسيه
الان هناك مواجهات تقول طالبان بانها شرسه
الان تحدث بينها بين طالبان وتنظيم داعشي
حركه الطالبان قادره بالفعل على يعني
مواجهه تنظيم داعش الذي يتمدد كما يرى
الكثير ويزيد عدد ايضا اعضاء المجندين في
خلال فتره القادمه هل الطالب قادر على ذلك
سريع
لا اعتقد انه ستواجه سوري جدا في اجتثاث
جاء داعش وحتى المجندين داخل الحكومه في
طالبان الذين جندتهم داعش بحكم همم قله
الكفاءه انعدام الكفاءه المتواجده وحتى ان
العمل الاستخبارات لديهم ما زال ضعيف وفي
من ناحيه اخرى هم يستخفون بهذه الناحيه اا
فلا اعتقد بان طالبان قادر في اقرب وقت
بانها همم تستطيع ان تسيطر على داعش وتنهي
عملياتها داخل افغانستان لان داعش تتمدد
داخليا داخل الحكومه في طالبان نعم خصوصا
في القطاعات الامنيه طالبان امامها مواجهه
يعني معركه خطيره وصعبه جدا في مواجهه
داعش
وقناه
مقاتلين هسه الذين كانوا معه بعدما
الانضمام الى داعش اشكرك شكرا
تتابعون المقابله الكامله لنائب المتحدث
باسم طالبان بلال كريم اليوم في رابعه
بتوقيت جرينتش السابعه مساء بتوقيت
السعوديه على شاشه العربيه
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض مؤتمر التعدين
الدولي وحضن المؤتمر الدولي بمشاركه عدد
من الوراء وثلاثه عشر كما شهد توقيع عشرات
الاتفاقيات لشركات المحليه وخارجيه منها
اعلان شركه لتاسيس شركه الاستثمار في اصول
التعدين دوليا بين صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه وشركه معه
زميل سالم الراجح ياخذنا في رحله بالارقام
عن مؤتمر التعدين الدولي في الرياضه
متغيرات كبيره يعيشها العالم نحو الثروه
الطاقه والمعادن هنا في الرياض اجتمع
الالاف من انحاء العالم لمناقشه مستقبل
المعادن والطاقه المتجدده في المنطقه
والعالم اثنى عشر الف مشارك من 130 دوله
و200 متعدد من خبراء ومختصين ناقشوا
وتوسعه نطاق الثروات المعدنيه ومستقبلها
ومستجدات قطاع الطاقه وغيرها من الملفات
على مداري يومين وخلال النسخه الثانيه من
مؤتمر التعدين الدولي ابرمت اكثر من 60
اتفاقيه بين جهات محليه ودوليه ابرز تلك
الشركات مشاهدينا اتفاقيه مشروع مشترك بين
الصندوق الاستثمارات العامه وشركه معادن
لتاسيس شركه للاستثمار في الاصول
التعدينيه في راس مال يبلغ
2007 287 مليون ريال
وتنص الاتفاقيه على التزام شركه معادن
وصندوق الاستثمارات العامه بتمويل الشركه
بمبلغ اجمالي يلامس اثني عشر مليار عند
الحاجه اذا مستقبل واعد جدا للتعدين في
السعوديه هذا ما اكده وزير الصناعه
السعودي بندر الخريف خلال المؤتمر الخريف
قال ان المسح الجيولوجي كشف عن كميات
كبيره من المعادن تقدر بخمسه ترليونات
ريالا سعودي
ايضا من الرياض مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي من مطار مؤتمر التعدين اهلا عبد
المحسن
لما الذي انتهى اليه المؤتمر
في ساعات
الختاميه تجري نقاشات ورش عمل خلال هذا
خلال هذا الوقت قبيله انعقاد او انتهاء
هذا المؤتمر في عام ثانيه الذي اصبح رقما
صعبا في المؤتمرات التعديل الدولي وجذب
الكثير من
المستثمرين والمسؤولين المختصين في
التعدين حول العالم المؤتمر ركز على منطقه
وسط وغرب اسيا وكذلك افريقيا فبالتالي
شاهدنا عدد كبير جدا من هذه المنطقه قدموا
بالاضافه الى همم اعداد اخرى قدمت تتحدث
عن وزراء من بريطانيا من دول مختلفه حضروا
لعقد الشركات لمناقشه ابرز التطورات
والتحديات التي تواجه قطاع التعديل لتصبح
السعوديه وهذه المنصه تحديدا واحده من اهم
المنصات عالميا في قطاع التعديل للمناقشات
العالميه وتطلع لرؤى مستقبليه في قطاع
التعذيب في الحقيقه تتحدث اكثر في عماد
المؤتمر مع النائب وزير الصناعه والثروه
المعدنيه المهندس خالد المديفر الذي
سيحدثنا عن هذا المؤتمر فيكم مهندس خالد
حدثنا في البدايه عن المؤتمر في ختامه في
في عام الثاني الذي حققه وما هي ابرز همم
الاهداف من هذا المؤتمر
خالد الاستديو الحقيقه انت موجود معنا
يمكن شفت الحراره وشفت
المستوى التمثيل العالمي العدد كبير ولله
الحمد ولكن الاهم من العدد والمستوى اللي
بشركات عالميه وتجميع دوله تجمع دولي يعدل
اكبر تجمع للوزراء ومختصاصين الحكوميين في
التعدين في العالم في التاريخ وليس فقط في
همم وهذا ما جعله المنصه الاساس كما سمعنا
اليوم من العديد من الرؤساء الشركات من
كبار شركات العالميه عندنا من اكبر خمس
شركات العالم اربع شركات موجودين معنا
وان شاء الله السنه الجايه كل كل الكبرى
شركات العالم 100% هيكونوا هنا لان هذا
المؤتمر
بحيويه المملكه بجذبيه المملكه في الطاقه
التي
تمدنا بها الرؤيه اصبح الملتقى الاهم
بشهاده جميعك الكثير وجميع الرؤساء شركات
هذه اللي جمعناهم مهندس خالد ربما ابرز ما
يحدث الان هو ما يحدث في القاعه التي
خلفها وهو ملتقى الفرص تتحدث عن سته مواقع
يتم طرح فيها فرص ما الذي يحدث في هذه
القاعه المهندس هو
اجتماع للدعوه فقط الحقيقه كان عندنا
تجربه جميله في الخليجيه المملكه الجديده
على التعدين هناك الكثير من الشركات
والمؤسسات
والرجال الاعمال السعوديه المهتمين في
التعدين لانه قطاع جديد قطاع نامي قطاع
سيكون احد قطاعات الاساسيه مملكه ولكن
الخبرات
ليست منتشره في المملكه لذلك هذا الاجتماع
يجمع بين شركات اجنبيه ترغب بالشراكه مع
بشراكه سعوديين ولديهم الخبره
ومستثمرين سعوديين
يودون الاستثمار في التعدين في المملكه
هذا التجمع 24 شركه سعوديه او 24 مستمر
سعودي و 27 شركه اجنبيه مهتمه في السماء
في السعوديه وتحتاج الى شريك سعودي فهذه
ان شاء الله بيخرج منها تحالفات هذه
تحالفات ستقدم على المناقصات الجايه او
تقدم مباشره على المنصه هناك ست فرص في
الطريق وتم تحديدها في الذهب والفضه
والنحاس والزنك وكذلك في الحديد فكل هذه
ان شاء الله ينتج عنها شركات سعوديه تبدا
من هذه الغرفه الصغيره ولكن ان شاء الله
تكون بحجم عالمي في السنوات القادمه في
الجزيره المهندس شكرا عبد المحسن شكرا اذا
خالد كما تشاهد ساعات الاخيره لانتهاء
مؤتمر التعدين الدولي الذي كان مخطط له
بان يصبح واحد من افضل خمسه مؤتمرات او
اكبرها حول العالم ولكنه سرعان ما اصبح
الثاني على مستوى العالم في عامه الثاني
فبالتالي اهتمام كبير جدا من قبل كافه
المستثمرين في قطاع التعديل حول العالم
وليس فقط في الفرص المطروحه في السعوديه
ولكن حتى في المواضيع التي يتم مناقشتها
لا سيما باستثمار
فرص الكبيره والحاجه الملحه همم المواد
التعديديه التي تستخدم في همم الطاقه
النظيفه ومنتجات ونتحدث عن السيارات
الكهربائيه وغيرها وكافه الصناعات الجديده
ونظيفه فبالتالي كان هنالك همم احاديث
كبيره حول
تطوير هذه
الصناعات او تعبت مساهمه في توفير هذا
الكم الهائل من الطلب المتوقع خلال اعوام
القليله القادمه التيما ان كثير من الدول
تطمح لان تصل الى صفر انبعاثات كربونيه
فبالتالي هذه المعادن مهمه جدا على مستوى
العالم وهما تم طرحه خلال ايام المؤتمر
الثلاثه خالد شكرا لك من الرياض مراسل
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل صندوق
الاستثمارات السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد تتواصلوا في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض عمليه فصل التوام السيامي
العراقيه عمر وعلي
مراسل العربيه فين العمليه تجري الان في
مراحلها الاخيره وهي المرحله الخامسه
فعليا حيث تمت عمليه الفصل المبدئي رئيس
الفريق الطبيه الدكتور
انضم الينا من مستشفى الملك عبد الله
التخصصي للاطفال في الرياض مراسل العربيه
هانيه سفيان هاني مرحبا بك انا كيف تتابع
العمليه الان
يبدو انه في مشكله في الاتصال مع هاني في
المستشفى
بنحاول نرجع او نعود اليه
راجعون
العراقي في السعوديه عبد الستار الجنابي
في لقائه مع العربيه على ان السعوديه دورا
مهما في الاعمال الانسانيه فيك على كافه
المستويات
على احد الدور اللي المهمه الانساني اللي
تقوم بالعذر الانسانيه في المملكه وخاصه
المركز الملك سلمان الاغاثه
صندوق السعودي للتنميه
الكثير من المبادرات والمشاريع الانسانيه
اللي هي طابعها انساني بحث هذه كلها هي
اللي تعكس صوره المملكه الانسانيه لدى
الاخرين وبالعراق ايضا مركز الملك سلمان
الى الكثير من المشاريع والاعمال التي
ارسلت رسائل واضحه وقوف المملكه وقياده
المملكه وشعب المملكه مع العراق وشعب
العراق وحكومه العراق الان
صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعوديه بضغط
المزيد من الاستثمارات في شركات
التكنولوجيا الاسيويه حيث شارك في كوريا
بتمويل ما قبل الطرح لشركه كاكاو انترنت
التي تدير مجموعه التطبيقات تنشر عروض
الرسوم المتحركه والروايات الشهيره عبر
الانترنت التي جمعت 930 مليون دولار من
مستثمر الاجانب اخر ظهرت وثيقه طلعت عليها
وكاله رويترزان بان صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه رفع حصته الياباني وكان صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه على حصص في ثلاث شركات
اسيويه لالعاب الفيديو
موقع صندوق السعودي للتنميه اتفاقيه مع
وزاره الشؤون الاقتصاديه الباكستانيه
للتمويل المشتقات النفطيه بقيمه مليار
دولار وذلك دعما للاقتصاد الباكستاني وكان
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني شريف جدد شكره
للسعوديه لتقديم المساعده قدرها مليار
دولار لاعاده تاهيل واعمار المناطق
المتضرره من الفيضانات وذلك خلال لقائه
وفدا من الصندوق السعودي للتنميه
رابعه ايضا مستمره في بعد الكلي وادي
الرمه حديث الناس في السعوديه وتساؤلات
حول تاريخه وواقعه اليوم واستمرار
الجرياني
نائب المتحدث باسم الطالبان يصف داعش
والظاهره التكفيريه ويوقلل من تاثيرها في
افغانستان
الاتفاقيات والاستثمارات المليريه
عمليه فصل الصياميه العراقي تتواصل في
الرياض اخر المراحل تقترب من نهايتها
وادي الرمم حديث الناس في السعوديه
تساؤلات حول تاريخه وواقعه اليوم واستمرار
جريانه
واعتماد الجريش والمكشوش طبقا وحلوى وطنيه
في السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد وتابع في تطورات عمليه
التوام العراقي ينضم الينا من مستشفى
الملك عبد الله التخصصي الاطفال في الرياض
مراسل العربيه حتى
نعم اهلا بك يا خالد واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه مره اخرى اذا في طابق مغترب وفي
مكان مختلف داخل ارجاع مستشفى الملك
عبدالله التخصصي للاطفال بوزاره الحرس
الوطني في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
وتحديدا في القاعه التي يتابع من خلالها
الطفلين عمر وعلي همم وعمليه الفصل التي
تمت وهي في المرحله الرابعه عبر هذه
الشاشه التي جهزت سوا وهيئه من قبل مستشفى
الملك عبد الله التخصصي التخصصي للاطفال
هنا في وزاره الحرس الوطني حتى يتم متابعه
عمليه الفصل
لعمر وعلي طبعا العمليه الان في المرحله
الرابعه انتهت وهي عمليه الفصل وكذلك
عمليه الفصل الكبد ايضا والان تتم المرحله
الخامسه او بدات المرحله الخامسه وهي
عمليه الترميم طبعا نحن نتحدث ان هناك
سريران همم السرير الاول لعمر والسرير
الاخر
عليه هنا طاقم طبي مجهز ومهيا وممارس
وكذلك في السرير الذي ايضا همم عليه ايضا
علي ا- طاقم طبي مكون من الدكتور عبدالله
الربيعه كمان يشاهد وكادر الطبي اخر وايضا
في السرير اخر الدكتور عبد الله مشان ومعه
الفريق الطبي
اخر هو الذي يتابع حاله عمر ولكن المشاهد
من داخل غرفه العمليات كنا نتابعها وايضا
نرصدها من خلال النشرات الماضيه ولكن في
الجهه الاخرى داخل هذه القاعه تحديدا
والتي كان فيها والد والده الطفلين الان
بالاصح ممكن ان نسميهما بعد ان تم عمليه
الفصل بدل من المسمى توام صيامي كانوا
يتابعان حاله عمليه الفاصل عبدالله او
محمد الكراه غير الكراغولي وهو والد
الطفلين الحاليين عمر وعبد الله لن اتحدث
لك عن العمليه ولكن ماذا كنت تفعل في هذه
القاعه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والله يعني كنا
يعني شعور لا يوصف والحمد لله ان العمليه
تكللت بالنجاح
والحمد لله سبحانه وتعالى ومن ثم الفريق
الطبي والذي راسه الدكتور عبد الله الربيع
جزاهم الله خير وما قصرهم بشيء
كنت قلب جدا
تخوف خاصه في بعض المراحل التي تمت في فصل
العمليه هل كان الاطباء اشعروك بالتفصيل
ماذا سوف او ماذا كان سوف يقومون به وماذا
سوف يحدث داخل غرفه العمليات التاكيد
بالتاكيد كان هناك خوف ورعب لدينا بس
الحمد لله انه طمنونا الكادر الطبي انه كل
شيء تحت السيطره والحمد لله واا مثل ما
نشاهد انه الان كل واحد على سرير ولله
الحمد نفسيا الحمد لله نحمد الله ونشكره
هل توقعت الكادر الطبي السعودي قبل وصولك
او اثناء حديثه
انه يتم نجاح العمليه على هذا الكادر وميه
بالميه ولله الحمد وهو مثل ما ذكر الدكتور
العراقي اسامه اسماعيل المشهداني وهو الذي
ارشدنا لهذا الفريق وهو الذي كلمني وقال
انه ان شاء الله يكون نجاح العمليه على يد
المركز همم في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مئه بالمئه نسبه النجاح والحمد لله مثل
الرحلات نحمد الله ونشكره بس
ان شاء الله
ما كما فعلت صباحا انت ووالدته اللهم امين
الى جلا الملك سلمان والا ولي عهد الامين
محمد بن سلمان على هذه المبادره الطيبه
وشكرا شكرا شكرا لك اذا هذه مشاعر والد
الطفلين عمر وعلي بعد ان تم فصلهما الان
ولكن
مرحله اخيره وهي المرحله السادسه وهي
عمليه الاطمئنان التامه التي لم تبدا حتى
الان ولكن يتوقع ان تستمر العمليه حتى
السابعه مساء بتوقيت المحلي السعودي وسوف
وهو فيكم ايضا بالتفاصيل عبر شاشه العربيه
التي كانت تنقل هذا الصباح عمليه
دخول عمر وعلي الى غرفه العمليات شكرا
من مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي للاطفال
في الرياض
تساولات عده حول وادي الرمل الذي يعادل
الجريان بعد سنوات من التوقف حول تاريخه
وسر تسميته وامكانيات استمرار جريانه
الجميله العنود العبدلي تعرفنا اكثر اولا
على وادي الرمان
[موسيقى]
التاريخيه في هضبه نجد الوادي متنزها عاما
لاهالي المنطقه بعد ان ردد الكثيرون بانها
او بانها المره الاولى التي يفيض فيها
الوادي منذ 14 عاما لماذا سمي وادي الرمه
بهذا الاسم خبير الارصاد الجويه الدكتور
خالد الزعاق قال ان تسميه جاءت من الفعليه
رمم اي ياكلوا كل جالسا في طريقه ويقع
معظم حوض وادي الرمه
بينما تقع اطرافه جنوب منطقه حائل وشرق
منطقه المدينه المنوره وشمالي وشمال غربي
منطقه الرياض ويبلغ طول هذا الوادي
مشاهدينا نحو 1200 كم تقريبا ويجعله اطول
الاوديه في شبه الجزيره العربيه عن
ظاهره علميه كما وصف تحدث في الجزيره
العربيه وهي جريان الماء في وادي الرمم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكبر ظاهره علميه تحدث عندنا في الجزيره
العربيه
جريان وادي الرمه ولهذا يسمى بشيخ الاوديه
علاوه على ذلك انه من معشوقنا لقد سمعنا
باوصاف له كملت فسرنا ما سمعنا واحيانا من
قبل رؤيته منا محبته والاذن تعشق قبل
العين
احيانا فهو معشوقنا وعلاقتنا مع وادي
الرمه علاقه حياتيه وعلاقه نفسيه العلاقه
الحياتيه يعمل على رفع مياه الابار
الجوفيه
ويقلل ملوحه هذه الابار علاوه على ذلك انه
يجدد خصوبه الارض وعلاقه نفسيه العلاقه
النفسيه تتلخص في اننا سعداء عندما نشاهد
هذا الوادي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وانا امثل عشق المنطقه لهذا الوادي فانا
انام واكل واشرب بجانبي هذا الوادي كانت
مسائله الركباني تخبرنا عن جابر بن حيان
افضل الخبري ثم التقينا فوالله ما سمعت
اذني باحسن مما رات
بصل
[موسيقى]
من عنيزه ينضم الينا نائب رئيس جمعيه
الطقس والمناخ الدكتور عبد الله المسني
الدكتور حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
دكتور ما تشاهده اليوم في وادي الرمه
يعني منظر مختلف تماما عن مكان عليه قبل
14 سنه ولا نحن امام تغير حقيقي اليوم
ربما في حاله هذا الوادي وعوده جريانه
لمكان عليه قبل سنين
اسعد الله مساء الجميع
الوادي في هذا العام ممكن يوصلنا بانه
جريان معتدل الى متوسط تقريبا
مقارنه
بالجريان الذي حدث عام 1982 1402 ايضا
جريان عام
1429 كان اقوى
واكثر من هذا الجريان الذي اقف امامه الان
واراء الضعف بدا
بالوادي
والجريان همم يتكرر كل تقريبا
20 25 سنه هذا الكلام قبل عقدين من الزمن
اما في هذه العقود بدا يتكرر وربما نستطيع
القول انه بكل 10 سنوات همم يجري جريانا
كاملا ونقصد بجريان الكامل من اهالي وادي
الرمه من مرتفعات حرت بني رشيد شرقي منطقه
المدينه حتى شرق القصيم حيث يحير عند
اعتاب نفود التويرات
رصدت كذلك في في كثير من المناطق المملكه
مع الموجات المطيره اللي استمرت لوقت يعني
وكذلك في الربع الخالي
دكتور انت شايف انه اليوم المنطق يعني
تغادر حاله مناخيه وتدخل في حاله مناخيه
اخرى
اخي خالد الناس تنسى ولكن القى الارقام
والقيم وسجلات المناخيه المسجله منذ اكثر
من 70 عاما في محطات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه خاصه المحطات التي انشات في
اورامكو تثبت ان كل ما يجري خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالحالات المطريه كل ما يجري هو
طبيعي ولا يمكن ان يعزع الى تغير مناخي
عدا عنصر درجه الحراره وهو الامر واضح جدا
ان هناك تغير مناخي على مستوى العالم
يتعلق بارتفاع درجه الحراره في كل الفصول
الاربعه وعليه الشتاء الذي نعيشه في
العقود المتاخره ليس
كاشئات التي كانت قبل 40 سنه اما الحالات
المطريه التي عشناها هذا العام فهي في
سياق والرتم المعتاد اللي امطار
في هذا الفصل
الشتاء او موسم الامطار ولكن الناس تنسى
وبالمناسبه هذه الحاله تعتبر حاله في
الواقع ايضا تاريخيه استثنائيه التي سميت
بحاله مدرار واستمرت لعشره ايام شاملات كل
مناطق المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبعض دول
الخليج الحدود
يعني مثلا
المرتفعات في مكه وفي جده همم اكتساؤها
بالخضره في الربع الخالي في كثير من
المناطق باستمرار الامطار كلها اثاره ردود
فعل من الناس همم حول بالفعل انه احنا
امام تغير مناخي كبير والبعد ربط بينها
وبين حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم بان
همم بعوده هذه الصحراء مروجا وانهارا بما
في معنا هل هناك علاقه بين الامرين دكتور
عبدالله من خلال متابعتك يعني
العالم كله يمر بحاله من التغير المناخ
المتطرفه
حتى تعود ارض العرب مروجا وانهارا وهذه
البساط الاخضر الذي نشاهده في تلال وجبال
منطقه مكه في الواقع ايضا معتاد ولكن بين
فتره وفتره طويله جدا لان الكاميرا اتقبل
40 و 50 سنه لم تكون موجوده ومتوفره عند
كل الناس
وليس هذه المناظر التي تسر الناظرين وان
نشاهدها في المنطقه الجنوبيه وهي فعلا
نادره الحدود ولكن همم يعني اعيد واقول ان
الحالات المطريه في المملكه الى الان لم
نجد لاصله بينها وبين تغير المناق ولا
يعني ذلك ان التغير المناخي العالمي لن
يؤثر على الامطار في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولكن انماذج المناخيه
ما في اي دراسه
لسنوات قادمه لحاله المناخ بناء على ما
يحدث او ما حدث مثلا
عن التنبؤات في عنصر المطر اذا بعض
النماذج المناخيه توحي الى ان الامطار سوف
تزود في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ما بين
خندق 15 الى 20% وبعض النماذج همم تقول
عكس ذلك انها سوف تنقص لذلك لا نستطيع ان
نترك على هذه التوقعات بعيده المدى فيما
يتعلق بانصر المطر اما عنصر درجه الحراره
في الناس كلهم يشعرون ان درجه الحراره قدر
ارتفعات واختلفت عن ما كانت عليه فيما سبق
شكرا دكتور عبد الله المسند نائب رئيس
جمعيه الطقس والمناخ من عنيزه
الجيش طبقا وطنيا في السعوديه والمنشوش
حلوى وطنيه معتمده هذا ما اعلنت وهيئه
فنون
مبادره روايات الاطباق الوطنيه واقل مناطق
وتولي المبادره او تتولى مسؤوليه الحصر
وتصنيف الاطباق المحليه الشهيره ذات
الارتباط الوثيق بالهويه السعوديه في جميع
المناطق في المملكه
على اصول الطائفي هيئه فنون الطهي في
وزاره الثقافه ماجد المهندس الاستاذ ماجد
في كل الوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
المملكه المعروف اللي في الشمال
تحديث 13
طبق وطني الطبق الوطني اشمل بشكل اكبر من
حكي من الناحيه الجغرافيه احنا ركزنا على
الجريش بحكم انه عنده قصه عنده قصه عميقه
جدا احنا مره ثانيه نركز على المسمى انها
روايات ايش نقصت فيها في الروايات نحكي عن
قصص المجتمع السعودي في ناحيه خلال الطبقه
هذا لما نحكي عن الجريش احنا نسميه سيد
الولائم او سيد المائده السعوديه همم
الغني ياكلوا في الصباح الفقير كان ياكله
في الليل وهو كان ازداد الرئيسي اللي كان
المجتمعي فعلا يحتاج ويعود عليه هو يحكي
في فتره الاحتفالات والولاء والاعياد في
السابق ما كانت الارزاز كانت هي الجريش هو
الاساس اللي كان ينطبخ فيه هو كان المحور
الرئيسي ان تقديم الاطباق واكرام الضيف
همم فيها نوع من الحفظ من النعمه برده
لانك انت من خلال عمليه الجرش انت تحافظ
على القمح والقشره حقه فبالتالي بس هذا
يكون في كل مناطق المملكه
انه احنا نحكي عن هو عظيم عظيم جدا في
مساله الاكلات التراثيه والتقليديه اللي
موجوده فيها
حتى الجيش موجود فيه في بلاد الشام موجود
في فلسطين موجود في العراق موجود في مناطق
كثيره ان يستند على ويكيبيديا وعلى كثير
من المواقع انت الاساس عندك جدا عميق
خصوصا في هذا الوصفه من ناحيه العادات
والتقاليد ومن ناحيه الوصفات فلما الحكي
على الجريش اليوم احنا نحكي عن الجريش
وبعض الاطباق المتشابهه والمماثله لهذا
الطبق مثلا عندنا في منطقه مكه والمدينه
شوربه الحب عندنا في منطقه الشرقيه وجبه
الهريس عندنا ايضا في المناطق الجنوبيه
عند التطبيق مشابه لها انا ما سكر الحين
في بالي عندي الحيسيه برده القديمه منها
شكرا
مطبوخ مع اللبن او مع المراه انت تحكي على
استخدام العناصر والاستفاده منها انت على
حفظ النعمه ما في شيء مهجور في هذه
الوصفات وفي هذه الاطباق انت تحكي عن
الابداع اللي موجود في اختلاف المناطق
الموجوده
سريع
المعيار الاساسي
الرقعه الجغرافيه لها وبرده وجوده كعنصر
قديم في المملكه هذه برضو النقطه جدا مهمه
احنا نحكي على اطباق كثيره موجوده في
المملكه لكن هذا قديم جدا ومتواجد بشكل
كبير اساسي وهو كذلك مره ثانيه هي روايات
احنا نحكي على قصص قصص قديمه جدا للمجت
قصه الجيش
بين سالم
عندنا احنا كمان في الجنوب وفي غيرها من
المناطق يعني في كمان
ميزه المكشوف انه نحنا برضو نحكي على
اطباق برضو مشابهه في التكنيك عندك
المصابين بالمراصير عندك خبز المقشوش في
الشمال في كذلك خبز اللحوح الموجود في
الجنوب عندك انت تشكل كبير في الناحيه هذه
المصالح هذا هذه موجوده في كل المناطق
المملكه لكن ميسي المكشوش من بنت كل
التكنيك هذه هو التكنيكي اللي موجود فيه
انت انت حاكيه على العجينه اول شيء اتكلم
من ناحيه التغذيه جدا اعلى انت ما تحكي
على عجينه رهفه عباره عن باتر او خليط
اللي يصب ومن ثم تطبخه على الصاجه
المغشوش ايضا في تقنيه الاعداد هو الوحيد
اللي تاخذه بالصاج وتقلب واخوه خالد على
النار بحيث انه يستوي يعني بالتالي انت
انت قاعد تطبخه من الجانبين فهذه جدا مميز
فيه فاحنا بالنسبه لنا شفناه انه جدي مميز
خلانا نركز عليه في هذا طبعا
هيطلع فيها تعريف كامل في مش هي الاطباق
المشابه له برده موجوده ضمن المناطق
المملكه الممتع ولذيذ يا استاذ ماجد بس
انا ما عاد عندي وقت والله كان المفروض
13 طبق لمناطق المملكه طالع واحنا اوريدي
حصرنا 10 اطباق لكل منطقه
مميزه للمنطقه ما هو متشابهه
الحلوى الوطنيه
احتفى مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز اللعب في
نسخته السابع بتسجيل حذاء الابل ضمن
التراث الثقافي غير المادي في اليونس
كنتابا
لا
[موسيقى]
يا مرحبا
معلش
اعلام
السفر
فلاش يا مرحبا
[موسيقى]
بالجيت وجيتي
وليتي جيتي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واتا يا
[موسيقى]
معليش يا ناس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]